تتشكل ملامح حراك دولي من اجل وقف المعارك
فقد قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ينطون
بلنكن ان بلاده تبذل جهودا لانهاء القتال
في السودان وفي مؤتمر مع نظيره الكيني عبر
الوزير الامريكي عن قلق بلاده بشان دوري
مجموعه فاغنرف في السودان وفي بلدان
افريقيا اخرى
لنعرف
ستعمل الولايات المتحده مع جميع الاطراف
بالتنسيق مع الشركاء الاقليميين والدوليين
لانهاء القتال في السودان والعوده الى
الانتقال لحكومه مدنيه نتواصل بشكل مباشر
مع البرهان واحمدتي للضغط عليهما لتمديد
وتوسيع هدنه عيد الفطر لتصبح وقفا نهائيا
ودائما للاعمال العدائيه
لكن قال ايضا ان واشنطن على تواصل مستمر
مع شركائها في المنطقه وخارجها من اجل
التوصل الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار في
السودان
تواصلنا مرانا خلال هذه الازمه مع مجموعه
من الدول وتحدثت بشكل مباشر مع نظراء في
السعوديه والامارات كما تواصل اعضاء من
فريق مع مصر ودول اخرى والمملكه المتحده
لتحقيق نفس الهدف وهو التوصل الى وقف
لاطلاق النار ووقف للاعمال العدائيه
واعاده البلاد الى مسار الانتقال الى
حكومه مدنيه